okay here you go go right no no oh
goodness okay you've probably seen some
musicians before but get ready my friend
huh okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
these people were not born when we
started making Lord of the Rings so it's
a big part of their lives and that's
that's very sweet isn't it and they'll
be able to see all six movies now and
show them to their kids that's what's
nice we've made classics and also it
will take nearly a day to watch it yeah
I was off school L once I think I did
I'm with my friend
look at all male school across the
street was an all-woman School Spelman
so we got our chili to our female
cheerleaders from there so I was the
only a volunteered to be a cheerleader
that year so I taught my roommate into
doing it and this is awesome we get to
pick all the girls so we picked them and
we got to travel all these other schools
to meet women are you a fan of Kim and
Kanye or do you hate them no I love I
mean Kim Kardashian has you know her I'm
she's a nice person like a canon of work
I can refer to necessarily yeah I'm a
huge fan of his music and yeah he and I
used to we used to have the same
personal trainer so we would we would
work out next to each other which was
bizarre we stay enthusiastic and you
follow the steps and you do the chant in
the morning I mean I was so I was hook
line and sinker you know you can open
your own office and like start your own
business and I did I like made it all
the way o ice open my own office 19 I
had my own business and and went to a
state in Colorado and I opened my own
office in Denver and put an ad in the
paper the same ad that I had answered
which said you like rock and roll music
you want to make money
is your life [ __ ] yeah your business I'm
gonna blow your boss a supermodel live
this life ring this number what are you
afraid of well I was gonna go with
flying but I think I'll go with girls
over 12
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
morale and Julie you're both part of the
despicable me family yes yes we never
met though did we on the on the on the
film no but I was honored to know and I
was working on the same project
so she's kind of taken
[Laughter]
one of the things they do it hang upside
down and whistle that's good nice nice
and the other one is another male of
species has got long quills coming out
of his tail and what he does is to turn
round and then flick his friend the cost
of a turn 40 I was offered three which
is in one year and it was sending me a
signal I felt how they felt about people
turning 40 so I felt bad and I and it
made me sort of I had a like a little my
backup you know and so no I didn't want
to play them so lots changed in the last
five years
[Music]
[Applause]
dijanna what was good what's that I
could I never I'm pretty thick but I've
never understood the thing that Morgan
Freeman said to you that oh so when I
was this was about ten years ago I did a
film with Morgan Freeman it was a really
small film and the first 10 pages or 10
minutes of the film are us to just
driving together in a car and talking
and it took three days to shoot and he
didn't talk to me the entire times like
in between takes right because he had so
much dialogue I learned later right okay
so he was just you know so in between we
wouldn't really chat and but we were in
the car together for three days and then
the third day he just turns to me and he
goes Jonah Jonah Bobo no banana fanna fo
fona
me Mom momona Jonah was like super
uncomfortable I didn't
more weird moments of my life
and I just didn't know what to say so I
just said thank you he said it was quiet
again then he said do me do your name
and he's like yeah do my name and I was
like Morgan Morgan Babur give me my mom
Morgan Morgan all right and then we
never spoke again
[Applause]
[Music]
it was powered up were born with trams
Allah the Kirk Spock McCoy [ __ ] con
so I wanna say like a Swiss guy
[Applause]